well everyone waits for a game-changer
to emerge we ask a simple question what
if it doesn't mean well Congress passes
another round of aid for small business
and it's Earth Day guys I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show today's
show is sponsored by expressvpn stands
up for your digital rights take action
at expressvpn dot-com slash band that is
expressive VPN dot-com slash Ben
alrighty so today's Earth Day are you
excited I'm excited everybody loves
earth they come on Earth Day it's the
best what's there not to love about
Earth Day I mean a holiday that was
created by a person who composted his
girlfriend I mean that that is a dude
who took Earth Day super seriously true
story the guy who started it killed his
girlfriend and put her in a trunk in his
closet where she proceeded to drip into
the bottom apartment which is how she
was originally but Earth Day is great
listen we all appreciate our environment
particularly when it's trying to kill us
I will say that my original take on
nature I stood up pretty well over over
time which is nature is trying to murder
you and basically all of human life is
about trying to avoid nature murdering
you the reason that I bring this up is
because this morning I'm starting to see
the pagan awakening of some members of
the radical many members of the radical
left suggesting that this is nature's
revenge nature's revenge now I have been
informed by reliable sources
that nature does not actually have
intent and I've been informed by a lot
reliable sources on the left that God
doesn't exist number one and then even
if God did exist nature does not have
intent right I mean evolutionary biology
suggests that basically it's survival of
the fittest out there that nature is
trying to kill you and that those who
survive survive so the idea that nature
is having her revenge because we will
mean to nature and now Mother Nature is
coming out and just blasting us mother
nature has decided to release a virus
unleash a plague upon us pretty pagan
pretty pagan crap and frankly I am a bit
upset with the Pope for pushing it so
Pope Francis actually pushed this
nonsense yesterday or today rather he
made an impassioned plea according to
Reuters for protection of the
environment on Wednesdays fiftieth
anniversary of the first Earth Day which
again is a pagan holiday
environmentalism has become a religion
for a lot of folks and complete with
with activities like we have to separate
our recycling and our trash even though
most of the time the recycling goes to
the same place as the trash does namely
to the dump or that it is more expensive
in many cases to recycle than it is to
throw things in the garbage I've talked
about articles in the past that actually
detail the cost breakdown to the
environment by the way in the entire
recycling movement recycling does some
good things it also does some things
that are pretty not great for the
environment including some fairly
significant carbon emissions depending
on how you process all of that but it's
become sort of a a ritualistic thing for
a lot of environmentalists to talk about
the environment as though it has its own
its own level of brute force intent
which of course it does not and and the
fact that the Pope is buying into it is
pretty amazing
Francis praised the environmental
movement saying it was necessary for
young people to quote take it to the
streets did he just what is obvious that
is there will be no future for us if we
destroyed the environment that sustains
us now listen I'm all in favor of
protecting the environment from in from
predations I'm all in favor of
environmental regulations that prevent
externalities prevent you from polluting
a river that I'm going to use prevent
you from just willy-nilly chopping down
forests for no apparent reason and those
regulations are good right otherwise you
end up with the so-called tragedy of the
Commons but the Pope's moral language
here with regard to the environment
itself is quite bizarre he recounted a
Spanish proverb proverb that God always
forgives man sometimes forgives but
nature never forgives well nature I mean
nature doesn't forgive because Nature
does not have the power to forgive if
you are looking for some sort of thing
that you can do that will make nature
nicer to you good luck with that
good luck with that most of human
history was marked by privation and
danger thanks to the environment and his
only technology that has allowed us to
surpass that we've forgotten about that
because we live in an industrialized
society we've forgotten about the fact
that danger isn't inherently it's just
an inherent part of life and that nature
is a very very dangerous place one of
the reasons that you live in comfort is
because of technology designed against
nature I'm not a big camping I know a
lot of people love camping I'm not a big
camping person because civilization was
basically designed to avoid camping was
decided to save a permanent roof
over your head and I understand getting
out there and enjoying nature really III
get it you know I want to take my walk
every day I want to go out and go for a
hike with my kids but this bizarre idea
that nature is taking revenge on us and
that this is a punishment for global
warming or somesuch
is really quite insane and we are
starting to see sort of Inklings of that
on the left an almost quasi celebration
it started off a few weeks ago in like
the in what they call the deep green
movement people who are celebrating look
at the cities going back to the animals
the cities being overrun by nature again
look how clear the sky is over Los
Angeles and what we'll get in a second
to the left's take on global warming
because the radical left and it's not
the entire left right most people on the
Left want to get back to work most
people who are liberals want to get back
to work and they're not into the whole
what if we just shut down all of human
civilization in that in this great but
I'll show you in a second how this is
starting to cross streams with some of
the environmental movement in the Pope
Francis said we see these natural
tragedies which are the Earth's response
to our maltreatment what like the earth
doesn't have its own paganistic capacity
he said I think if I ask the Lord now
what he thinks about this I don't think
he would say it's a very good thing it
is we we have is we who have ruined the
work of God I mean right now I'm fairly
certain it is the environment that is
that is responsible for you know
hundreds of thousands of deaths around
the world tens millions of people out of
work the Earth's response torment the
earth did not respond the earth is not
alive says we have sinned against the
earth against our neighbor and in the
end against the Creator you can sin
against your neighbor and you can sin
against the Creator and you can say that
that failure to protect the environment
is a sin against the Creator I don't
know how you sin against an inanimate
object I don't know how it's possible to
do that so this sort of like Frank
coming from the Pope is pagan nonsense
I'm kind of shocked that he said oh this
except that you talked about the notion
of environmental sin before so it's I
find it puzzling that's all I will say
about that however this does cross
streams as I say with with other parts
of the environmentalist movement we'll
get to that in just a moment and then
we'll get to non Earth Day related news
like actual important news we'll get to
that in just one moment
first let us talk about the fact that
when you are running a business HR
issues can kill you especially right now
you have to make sure that you are HR
compliant you just do not have room at
the margins to be spending money on an
entire a chart
in steam and right now there are all
sorts of regulations about what you can
do with salaries even though you have to
engage in cost-cutting there all sorts
of regulations about how you bring
people back on board regulations about
overtime all these things can really
destroy your business if you're not
careful and this is why you need Bambi
ba MBE HR Manager salaries are not cheap
but Bambi was created specifically for
small business and getting dedicated HR
manager craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just 99 bucks a
month with Bambi you can change HR from
your biggest liability to your biggest
strength your dedicated HR manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day to day all for just 99
bucks a month month to month there are
no hidden fees you can cancel anytime
you didn't start your business because
you wanted to spend all your time on HR
compliance so head on over to Bambi comm
slash Shapiro right now to schedule your
free HR audit that is Bambi comm slash
up here I'll be am to the B EE comm
slash up here I'll go check them out
right now for that free HR audit okay so
as I mentioned sort of last notes on the
environmentalist movement that is using
this as using this pandemic as sort of a
bizarre pagan belief system in which
because we drove cars now Nature has
taken her revenge by killing eighty-five
year olds like that that is that is how
nature has gone about doing this one
aspect of this is the is the green
movements focus on global warming so
Eric holds house who's just that very
very clever fellow
apparently he writes on climate at the
cores he calls himself an eco socialist
and he wrote this so CBC News put out
this this notice the corona virus
pandemic is expected to drive down
carbon dioxide emissions by six percent
this year the world media raw media
logical organization says it would be
the biggest annual drop since World War
two and Eric holthouse wrote this this
is roughly the same pace the IPCC says
we need to sustain every year until 2030
to be on pace to limit global warming to
1.5 degrees Celsius and hit the Paris
climate goals this is what rapid
far-reaching and unprecedented changes
in all aspects of society looks like
we're doing it it's possible where you
need to take some serious time and
energy during this pandemic to look
around and see what parts of this new
way of living we can keep
like less air travel and what parts we
can like huge unemployment there is a
balance we'll find it that's the whole
point of a green new deal we just need a
just transition for workers and those
who have been marginalized by the
excesses of the capitalist system that
got us into this mess we can build a
better world for everyone out of the
ashes of the old one and all I can think
of here is that Monty Python sketch with
with Jesus on the cross singing always
look on the bright side of life
no the global pen that make it's telling
hundreds of thousands of people and tens
of millions people are out of work and
can't feed their families narrow cold
cuts like yes we can do this
indefinitely and we can bring down the
climate by 1.5 degrees Celsius over the
next hundred years if we just keep this
up for like the next decade if we just
figure out how to do this for like the
next decade okay sure sure
yeah and these are the people who
supposedly are deeply concerned about
about humanity and our future mmm-hmm
great okay meanwhile in other news the
Senate has now passed its bill for small
business that was held up for a week for
no apparent reason that was exciting
stuff according to The Wall Street
Journal the Senate bill was struck last
night it was a deal with the White House
she was created Tuesday to send hundreds
of billions of dollars in fresh aid to
small businesses and hospitals that's
the federal government's latest efforts
to keep pace with the twin economic and
public health crises created by the
corona virus pandemic the Senate on
Tuesday evening passed the four hundred
eighty four billion dollar bill by a
voice vote sending it to the House for
an approval expected on Thursday
President Trump said on Twitter he
supported the legislation its final
components were hammered out between top
White House officials and congressional
leaders in the early morning hours on
Tuesday in the package which lawmakers
dubbed an interim emergency bill so we
have now spent by the by the Senate by
that by the Congress of the United
States who've now spent an excess of two
point six trillion dollars in the last
four weeks that does not include the
four trillion dollars expended by the
Treasury also includes funding to ramp
up the country's testing for new
coronavirus it does not include funding
sought by Democrats for hard-hit state
and local budgets which was instead
pushed off to the next round of stimulus
negotiations as I've said you got to be
real careful about that it's one thing
to fill in the gaps created by federal
policy it is another thing to pay off
California for California's crap policy
for the last ten years running up its
debt or Illinois or New York top
Republicans signaled concerns about the
mountains that would play a bigger role
in talks about future stimulus aid
which it should we cannot spend this
money endlessly guys and by the way the
original care sack was filled with holes
it now turns out that the Republican
objection that the care is an act which
paid people twelve hundred dollars a
month and then added six hundred dollars
a month on top of that so that some
people were making more money by staying
home than by going to work that has
actually had some fairly significant
effects it turns out a lot of people
like okay well I'm not going back to
work why would I go back to work we've
taken calls on the radio show from
business owners who are going to their
employees and saying we want you to come
back to work so we can get a small
business loan because you have to
maintain ninety percent employment to
get the small business loan through the
Paycheck Protection Act and employees
being like no I'm not coming back to
work I'm making more money staying at
home because that's what happens when
you create perverse incentives every
government program sucks this one might
be necessary and it also might suck both
of those things can be true at the same
time the the Democrats held this thing
up for a week for no reason at all Kevin
McCarthy the house Minority Leader he
says you're gonna have to explain like
name one thing that Nancy Pelosi has
done well during this pandemic cuz all
she's been doing is holding up a drily
f-- bills in the middle of a crisis and
that will lead to further unemployment
name me one productive thing speaker
Pelosi has accomplished in this pandemic
when President Trump in January 31st put
in the banned from China February 24th
she asked people to gather together in
San Francisco she actually fought the
ban when we wanted to put the cares act
together she came in held it up now we
had a small business program working
she's now held up the money there's 700
thousand small business applications in
right now trying to keep their doors
open
last week we watched five million people
new numbers for unemployment
how many more millions of policies
layoffs will we have to endure before
she'll put people before politics and
the answer is as many as Nancy Pelosi
sees fit to make people endure so that
she can dump a bunch of pork into each
one of these programs at the core of our
agreement says Mitch McConnell is three
hundred twenty billion dollars more for
the Paycheck protection program which is
already saving millions of small
business jobs and helping Americans get
paychecks instead of pink slips that
those funds were exhausted inside of
like two weeks businesses are just
shutting down everywhere because nobody
the market doesn't exist I mean the
reason that oil prices sank to negative
levels as of May 1st is because nobody
is driving to work I mean there's nobody
on the roads there's nobody
is going out Eric holds house couldn't
be happier I mean we are saving the
earth all he had to do was make all of
human civilizations stop dead and put
tens of millions of people out of work
Democrats were pressing for changes to
the program to widen into access to
loans sixty billion dollars will be set
aside for small midsize and community
lenders the a separate program the
economic injury disaster loan fund aimed
at delivering a mix of grants and loans
at sixty billion dollars in the
legislation loans can be forgiven if
businesses maintain the size of their
workforce so it's good that this passed
Nancy Pelosi held it up again to
basically achieve nothing and this is
the second time that she has done this
right she held up the cares act for a
week after it had already been hammered
out by Schumer and McConnell she held it
up for a week for no apparent reason she
held this one up for a week for no
apparent reason because she's just awful
she's just awful in every possible way
here she was on MSNBC this morning
suggesting Republicans had held up the
bill even though again the deal had been
hammered out and then she jet set it in
from her very expensive palatial estate
in California to hold the thing up we're
very pleased that the Senate finally
accepted the fact that we needed more
money for testing for hospitals for
lower and lower smaller businesses to
participate in the paycheck protection
program Oh Mitch McConnell likes to say
we delayed the bill no he delayed the
bill a month a two weeks ago he came to
the floor and said this is all we're
doing just at 250 and that Democrats
were reunited House and Senate the
Senate Democrats went to the floor and
said no no to that we have a better idea
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope no
bill basically did not change very much
overtime
Nancy Pelosi did not earn much more in
the bill it was just a holdup
okay so meanwhile all of this leads to
the asking of a question none of this is
sustainable right we can't just keep
spending money like this at a certain
point we're gonna have to inflate the
currency there's no market for our debt
at a certain point we're gonna start
floating 50 and 100 year bonds and you
just can't do this for very long there's
just no way to do it in a country of 330
million people and the engine of
economic civilization you cannot do this
indefinitely so the question becomes how
do we reopen obviously and the real
question becomes what exactly are we
supposed to wait for like what is the
what is the level of waiting we are
supposed to engage in what
we waiting to happen to allow us to
reopen some people are saying we're
waiting for a vaccine well the vaccine
ain't arriving okay it's not arriving
anytime soon at best 12 to 18 months by
the way there is zero evidence so far
that there will even be a vaccine at all
I mean like at all at all the flu
vaccine is not particularly effective
the reason it's not particularly
effective is because the flu virus
mutates it we have yet to come up with a
single vaccine for a corona virus that
is actually a hundred percent effective
or 90 percent effect or anything close
to it a corona virus is its own sort of
strain it's very difficult to come up
with a vaccine for it and according to a
new study a vaccine is not gonna be
forthcoming maybe maybe ever we'll get
to that in just one site doesn't mean
we're not gonna get some treatments but
we need to be realistic about what the
future looks like if we hope to get back
to anything presuming normal or even
remotely approaching normal we'll get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact you're spending an
awful lot of time on screens right
you're following the news you're
watching Netflix well what about the
fact that all that blue light is
affecting your sleep it's affecting your
eyes might be giving you headaches well
what you really need our Felix grey
glasses your favorite devices are a
major source of blue light whether it's
your phone or your tablet or your
computer or your TV and this can create
ice strain right bright screens in the
dark room that creates eyestrain ice you
get headaches fairly regularly from blue
light then I started using my Felix gray
glasses Felix gray glasses they are
first rate because they filter out 90%
of blue light in the most damaging range
they eliminate 99% of glare through a
proprietary industry-leading lens
technology that is only available to
Felix gray this is better than those
lenses you're gonna get online where
people just sort of paint something on
the lens and then it starts cracking and
lazing law that's not Felix grey 9 and
10 Felix gray customers report
significant symptom relief with over
200,000 happy customers Felix grey isn't
the right choice it is the only choice
for long lasting and durable relief for
the eye strain that comes from blue
light and it's you awake at night
you can order online the glasses shipped
directly to you with a hard case and
lens cloth included you can try them for
30 days risk-free and if your screens
aren't easier on the eyes you just send
them back for a full refund so you
really have nothing to lose here go to
felix great glasses comm /ban for the
absolute best quality blue light
filtering glasses on the market the
proprietary technology means that the
lenses themselves are better
that's fel ixg ra y felix grey glasses
comm slash then start taking care of
your eyes feel better it works
feliks great glasses calm sighs been
against risk-free you tried for 30 days
you can send it back if you don't like
them
Felix grey glasses calm slash Ben okay
so let's go through the sort of future
here what the future looks like so I've
got good news and I've got bad news okay
so why don't we start with the bad news
because that's what I always do I always
start with that is we get that out of
the way so here is the bad news there
may not be a vaccine and for all the
talk about a vaccine we're gonna develop
a vaccine everyone's working on a
vaccine as I say there's been very
little evidence that vaccines for
coronavirus have been particularly
successful remember it took us like 30
years to even come up with a drug
cocktail that was effective against
hiv/aids so the idea that you're gonna
come up inside of a year with a vaccine
for a corona virus seems fairly
difficult also The Jerusalem Post
reports a new study in China has found
that the novel coronavirus has mutated
into at least 30 different variations
showing the medical officials have
vastly underestimated the overall
ability of the virus to mutate so it's
mutating then you're not gonna be able
to create a successful vaccine for it
and meanwhile the CDC director is saying
that the second wave in winter could
theoretically be even worse
Robert Redfield spoke with the
Washington Post he said there's a
possibility the assault of the virus on
our nation next winter will actually be
even more difficult than the one we just
went through when I've said this to
others that kind of put their head back
they don't understand what I mean so you
know the reason that he is saying that
is if the virus is still around and if
people go out and they are back in
school and they're going about their
business
well then presumably the spread will be
wider I mean right now the spread is not
all that wide because everybody has
locked down and it depends on area so
there's an article that I saw today in
spiked online magazine talking about the
effectiveness of lock downs from the
article is by a guy named Wilfred Reilly
who's a political scientist and he
points out that states that have not
lockdown are not doing worse than states
that have locked down the seven states
that have not locked down our Arkansas
Iowa Nebraska North Dakota South Dakota
Utah and Wyoming the states reported
thirty 76021 nine seven twenty and two
deaths respectively for an average of
twenty two point three deaths throwing
in South Carolina the state's average 33
deaths if you measure up those states
against the rest of the United States
what you see is that they're actually
doing significantly better than the rest
of the United States now the ants
that has nothing to do with those states
don't have lock downs the other states
do have lock downs it has to do with
population density obviously okay and
you can adjust for population density
sort of but you can't really adjust for
the fact that New York City is a
massively massively populous place that
is responsible for something like 30
percent e52 30 percent of all deaths in
the United States are just New York City
so really heavily populous places you
might need lock downs if you hope to
curb the spread of this thing but if
you're looking at Utah probably not
people just live further apart the risk
factors are not the same
you can adjust for population in the
stats but it doesn't completely adjust
for populations in in the stats okay so
if you the if you extend this more
broadly across the world it is not clear
that lock downs are going to be
particularly effective at least not for
long because they as people go out
they're going to infect each other again
so what exactly can we hope for well we
can hope for are some sort of drug
reductions here right we can hope for
the success of that that Gilead
pharmaceuticals drug res mid appear we
that one we can REMSA Devere we can we
can hope for the effectiveness of that
particular drug we can hope that some of
the new techniques that are being used
like immunosuppressants because there's
a belief that maybe cytokine storms are
leading to strong and immune response is
leading to overloaded system basically
we can hope for that we can't really
hope for the effectiveness of
hydroxychloroquine anymore there's a new
malaria study on hydroxychloroquine a
nationwide study when 368 patients who
was the largest look so far at
hydroxychloroquine with or without a
thorough myosin the study was posted
online and it found that 28% of those
who were given hydroxychloroquine plus
usual care died versus 11% of those
getting routine care alone
22% of those getting the drug plus
azithromycin tied to the difference
between that group and the usual care
was not considered large enough to rule
out other factors hydroxychloroquine
made no difference in the need for a
breathing machine either so
hydroxychloroquine has not been
effective there were scientists in
brazil they stopped part of a study
testing chloroquine which is an older
drug similar after heart where the
problems developed in one quarter of
people given the higher doses of 2 being
tested
so Plaquenil which is the on-brand
version of the drug has not been
effective against this sort of stuff
there was anecdotal evidence that maybe
it was working but it appears not to be
meanwhile there's another drug that is
being put out in Israel
a kovat 19 treatment called pleura stem
which is now being utilized and tested
in the United States there's a report by
the company showing that six critically
ill coronavirus patients in Israel
considered high risk for mortality or
treated with pleura stones placenta
based cell therapy product and survived
according to preliminary data provided
by the Haifa based company there was one
u.s. case where this was treated that
patient was critically ill with
respiratory failure failure due to acute
respiratory distress syndrome was
intubated in an ICU for three weeks so
they're hoping that maybe this will be a
mitigating a mitigating circumstance
that's probably the best that we can
hope for at this point is that by the
time we get to fall there are some new
drugs on the market that help curb the
effect of this thing but other than that
I don't think they're gonna be a lot of
major changes until the fall other than
the development of drugs I don't think
there's gonna be a lot of major changes
until the fall so what are you locking
down until is the question like what is
the purpose of locking down so if you're
locking down until you have curbed the
spread such that we can actually measure
hotspot increases as I mentioned
yesterday that's fair right we want at
least get it to the point where you can
identify a hotspot when it arises that's
fine
once the state has done that that's
about all they can do and that brings us
to a little bit of good news and
possible strategies we'll get to that in
just one moment first let us talk about
the fact that perhaps you're losing your
hair right now perhaps perhaps stress is
making you lose your hair perhaps male
pattern baldness runs in your family it
runs in mine
two out of three tubes will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 the best way to
prevent hair loss is to do something
about it while you still have hair that
is on your head used to be able to go to
a doctor's office for hair loss
prescriptions one that much fun now you
can't even do that so why not go get
keeps they make it easy and they will
deliver your medication every three
months you can say goodbye to pharmacy
checkout lines and awkward doctor visits
you can visit the doctor online and get
the hair loss medication delivered
directly to your door prevention is key
keeps treatments can take up to four to
six months or more to see the results
it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair you
will save hey I have been using keeps
myself and I will say that I believed
that I was losing hair at a
significantly more rapid rate then now I
think pretty much I have stalled the
hair loss which is a which is a good
thing if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keeps calm slash
pens receive your first month of
treatment
for free that is ke e UPS comm / Ben
keeps calm / man and you get your first
month of treatment for free which is a
solid deal forgetting to keep your hair
keeps calm / then okay so in a piece of
good news despite all of this as dr.
Debra Brooks said yesterday the United
States still has one of the lowest death
rates on planet Earth
so the talk about how the United States
has completely botched this and
mishandled this there's this massive
disconnect in the media between how they
think the US has handled this and how
the US has actually handled this if you
look at deaths per million in the United
States we rank right in the middle of
European countries we are not the worst
in the world we don't have the worst
health care system in the world our
systems were not overwhelmed voice
systems were overwhelmed in Italy and
are now being overwhelmed in Japan all
the talk of how the United States
healthcare system it's so Byzantine and
it's so terrible and all it's just crap
it's just not true okay we have a one
city that has a in extraordinarily dense
population with a lot of people with
pre-existing conditions a lot of elderly
folks and the death rates there are
exceedingly high even there the health
care system was not overwhelmed here's
dr. deborah birx pointing out that we
still have one of the lowest death rates
in the world
they have been on the front lines now
for weeks and weeks and weeks and so no
matter what city they have been in they
have not seen the relief that we've been
able to talk about at the at light at
the end of the tunnel because of the
delay in hospitalizations and deaths so
to our health care providers to our
respiratory therapists and to everyone
in the labs thank you for the work that
you're doing to protect Americans and
give us one of the lowest mortality
rates in the entire world okay and that
is good news it is also good news that
we are seeing a study out of Stockholm
Sweden I honestly don't understand why
people are so negative about Sweden like
I understand if you don't like their
policy where you don't you think the
policy is the wrong policy that's fine
like policy critiques are fine
there are people who seem to be actively
rooting against what Sweden is doing
right because there may be they like the
lockdown policy so much that they're
rooting against Sweden or they're
rooting against Georgia like their sort
their sort of hoping against hope that
something bad happens in Georgia to
convince people to stay home across it
you should be rooting for the success in
Sweden according to the Swedish experts
they are now saying they're now saying
that there will be a fairly high
percentage of people who have been
infected in Sweden in very short orders
they are approaching
immunity that is Sweden's approach right
you sort of let people walk around and
be responsible we I've now asked pretty
much everybody left right and center
where we are going to end up in terms of
actual policy the answer is we will end
up doing what Sweden does the only
question is whether we do that sooner or
whether we do that later and as we are
seeing some states are doing it sooner
and some states are doing it later and
pretending that all states are
equivalent is ridiculous the new
york-based media is so angry at Georgia
for suggesting reopening of shops and by
the way just because you say that shops
can reopen does not mean that shops will
reopen many shops are not reopening in
Georgia many shops are saying listen we
don't have the capacity to do
temperature checks we don't have the
ability to socially distance so we're
just not going to open until the spread
has been slowed a little bit more that
the media I think completely got wrong
the Georgia policies as well because
those suggestions seem to be that people
are gonna willy-nilly go out bowling no
masks no social distancing then people
are gonna go to restaurants and spit on
each other that is not the case in order
for you to reopen your business you have
to take certain preliminary steps like
everyone has to be masked everybody has
to socially distance right enforceable
by law that's in the Georgia order Brian
Kemp who's the governor of Georgia was
on Fox News with Martha McCallum and he
was explaining the policy can you
explain why you would start with those
kinds of businesses on day one well
those are the ones were closed though
the businesses in Georgia are still
currently opening under the order that I
have now and we're coming down I think
that's what a lot of people don't
understand but you also have to give
that Fitness owner or that owner and a
hair salon the you know the ability to
be able to be a partner in this fight
that we're in you know this is going to
take some common sense our people in our
state have learned a lot through this
they have helped us be a solution to the
problem to flatten the curve and to
start getting on the other side of this
ok people on the Left are wildly angry
and Brian Kemp for doing this right like
they should be rooting for it to work
right I mean because that way we can all
start tranching back into work would you
be the idea people who are vulnerable
will still be out of the workforce
people who have pre-existing conditions
people who are elderly people who live
with people who are older right those
people will be last to go back to the
workforce because you don't want to
expose people but we're gonna have to
start getting back to something that
approaches a workforce at this point the
the media were fighting mad about this
so Chris Hayes over at MSNBC says this
is reckless it's illogical it's just
terrible
is Georgia doing something like this
look at the state of Georgia which is
about to reopen a wide range of
businesses under Republican Governor
Brian Kemp if that sounds insane to you
we're not alone and for the record
Georgia does not meet the white house
guidelines it does not have a 14 day
trajectory of declining cases it is
tested less than 90,000 people out of a
population of more than 10 million
mayors in Georgia are describing the
governor's decision as reckless
dangerous and illogical okay well those
mayor's are ignoring the fact that
actually the infection rate is now below
1 in Georgia if you actually look at the
stats in Georgia what you'll see is that
there's an increasing number of positive
tests but if you chart that against the
number of tests overall that are being
taken that chart shows the lines
diverging meaning that hugely increasing
number of tests slightly and
consistently increasing number of
positive cases you can actually see the
chart if you're watching the show that
red line is the number of total tests
being taken in Georgia that blue line is
the number of positive tests what you
would expect to see is the blue line
trending up at a faster rate as the
number of test increases instead what
you're seeing is a consistency in the
number of tests that are coming back
positive which is a smaller percentage
than the total number of tests that are
coming back that are better that are
coming back in Erik Erikson who's a
radio host in Georgia and he says the
the infection rate does not get talked
about a lot it's the measure of a
virus's ability to reproduce the
reproduction rate if the RT which is
what it's called is above 1 the virus
will spread if it's below 1 the virus
will stop spreading health care experts
have been telling us since March people
need to shelter in place to get the the
RT below 1 once it was below when we
could start slowly reopening in Georgia
the state is below 1 not only that but
daily new cases continue to fall here
are the present numbers in Georgia based
on daily new cases April 14th 830 April
15 634 April 16th 661 April 17th 537
April 18th 256 April 19th 157 April 20th
96 April 21 23 the trend is remarkably
good the virus is definitely declining
so Georgia is in fact flattening the
curve in Georgia is flattening the curve
so why exactly are people rooting
against all of this III do not
understand so Sanjay Gupta over
TNN he was saying it's clear that we're
not ready to open parts of the country
look even even Andrew Cuomo in New York
is saying that elective surgeries in
parts of New York that are not in New
York City
should be allowed businesses in New York
are gonna reopen it's not gonna be in
New York City first here's Sanjay Gupta
with Chris Cuomo we are clear that the
virus is still out there we are clear
that we are not ready it is clear what
the guidelines are and that we haven't
met them and it's also clear that a lot
of people Chris are frightened about
this they're frightened to go out so you
open up businesses but people are not
likely to go is that door knob safe did
that person get tested has this place
been sterilized what about the
ventilation I mean all these questions
still coming up among people because
people are you know they're
understandably worried right but what if
none of those things change really what
if they're done those things change what
if the testing is in place and that
doesn't mean people aren't walking
around infected it just means that you
can identify a hotspot all the things he
mentioned are probably going to be part
of the new reality is that door knob
infected was this table sterilized our
people near me carrying it right all
that is going to be part of the new
reality that's just the way that it
works okay then that that is the reality
until there's new treatments that come
out a vaccine as I say is I think
unlikely that's we're gonna have to deal
with the increased risk and we're going
to have to go back to a certain level of
reality because this cannot last okay
what is happening right now simply is
not palatable it's not something that
can last and as we will see the federal
government is gonna take some steps to
step in if states continue to lock down
indefinitely without any sort of actual
measurement any metric of when it's safe
like by Gupta's standard there there is
no metric by which it is safe to go back
to work but if we can't go back to work
until everybody feels secure that the
virus is no longer out there well then
we're gonna get the Eric Holt hat
solution of being home for the next ten
years which is not national solution it
will get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that if you have a medical problem that
is really affecting you right now it's
tough to go to the doctor's office and
if it's something that would be
embarrassing to talk to you about a
doctor in person anyway well maybe you
weren't doing it in the first place well
this is why you should have Roman our
friends at Roman have spent years
building a digital platform that can
connect you with the doctor licensed in
your state all from the comfort of home
and help you deal with conditions like a
reptile dysfunction or hair loss or cold
sores just grab your phone or computer
complete a free online visit you'll hear
back from the US
physician within 24 hours if the doctor
decides the treatment is right for you
Romans pharmacy can ship your medication
to you with free two-day shipping you
also get free unlimited follow-ups with
your doctor anytime you have questions
or you want to adjust your treatment
plan with Roman there are no commitments
you can cancel anytime
getting this medical issue taken care of
quickly and easily and discreetly would
be important in any time now that you
are home all the time you can't go to
the doctor anyway and it's embarrassing
why not get it taken care of you should
go get it taken care of right now so why
sit around with a medical problem if
you're struggling with EG hair loss cold
sores or other issues go to get Roman
comm / Benton for a free online visit
and free 2-day shipping that is get
Roman calm / Ben for that free online
visit free two-day shipping again get
Roman Calm / Ben that's get Roman Calm /
Ben okay in a minute we are going to get
to president Trump's immigration order
and people being crazy about it we're
also going to get to Democrats
maintaining two separate positions one
the actual position which is that the
Trump administration has done a pretty
good job getting them resources into
that the Trump administration is
responsible for every evil on planet
earth we'll get to all of that in a
second first being locked inside right
now
it requires double the excitement what
could be more exciting than this and
this oh yes I am holding up - count them
- that's right I can count
- leftist here's tumblr what is this
sorcery well right now when you become a
daily wire insider plus or all-access
member you get a second left his here's
tumblr I'm not lying - I'm not kidding
with Bernie Sanders out of the race for
president one tumblr was not enough to
hold all of the leftist tears the
tumblers are overflowing and that means
we have to get them out the door to you
daily wire members get many amazing
benefits including of course the
magnificent irreplaceable singular
leftist here's tumblr you also get an
ad-free website experience access to all
of our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show access to the mailbag and now
exclusive election insights op-eds from
moi daily where members also get to ask
us questions during backstage you get to
participate in our all-access live
that's the brand-new interactive
programming featuring one of the daily
wire host as we hang out with you each
night at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. pacific
where chef of daily wire backstage
tonight a socially distanced a daily
wired backstage on monday night we did
an all-access i was doing that all
access and i was allowing people to get
a peek into the gun show this content
for our all-access members has been
temporarily opened up to all membership
levels at least for
at the moment so again now's a great
time to become an insider plus or
all-access member double your tears with
two left is tears tumblr just go to
daily wire.com slash subscribe to get
started and get 10% off with coupon code
Shapiro that is daily where dot-com /
subscribe coupon code Shapiro also
remember we have a backstage tonight at
4 p.m. Pacific so stop by for that we
have a few surprises fun surprises
planned for tonight's backstage to make
sure that you tune in and join us over
there you're listening to the largest
fastest core and conservative podcast
and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so there seems to be the sort of
panicked belief that we are not going
anywhere until there's a vaccine and I'm
part many in the media many Democrats
that somehow there's gonna be a deals
next Mackinac that there will be some
outside intervention that will fix all
of this tomorrow and part of that is our
attention span in modern society is five
seconds long and so you're constantly
refreshing Twitter to see if if somebody
has come up with a cure part of that is
also our risk level in society has
dropped so dramatically that we are not
willing to undertake certain risks and
listen I'm not saying that if you are
elderly or vulnerable if you don't have
a pre-existing condition and when I say
elderly I really mean above age 60 that
you should be out running around
willy-nilly no problem right you should
be taking all the measures you can take
to keep yourself safe if you're in
regular contact with those people you
should be taking measures to keep those
people safe all of that happens to be
true it also happens to be true that
your baseline level of risk if you are
young and healthy is nearly zero it is
extremely extremely low and if governors
are waiting for something I'm not sure
what they are waiting for once you have
again lowered the rate to the point
where your health care system will not
be overwhelmed and - you can actually
identify hotspots as they grow that's
pretty much all you can do well Attorney
General William Barra said on Tuesday
the DOJ is gonna consider supporting
people in groups will allege that their
rights have been violated by Pan Simon
policies which is good you're starting
to see these bizarre videos emerge all
over the country of police arresting
people doing like absolutely nothing hey
there's a video that was floating around
Twitter and unless there's more to the
story it's egregious of a mother being
arrested because she took her kid to the
park like seriously enough like this is
not sustainable it's just not
sustainable the American people should
not stand for this kind of garbage I
will say I've never been proud of
America and I was when I saw the story
the Bill DeBlasio had requested that
everybody in New York send tips to the
to the mayoral toe in the mayoral office
of people who are not socially
distancing snitch on your neighbors and
instead he was inundated X he said he
was inundated with people's hurts of
their junk America was already great
here was Attorney General William Byers
saying listen if governors are pursuing
policies that violate people's civil
liberties and violate their
constitutional rights and there is not
evidence to back those policies we are
going to sue those governors I think the
president's guidance has been as I say
superb and very commonsensical
and I think a lot of the governor's
are following that and you know to the
extent that governor's don't and impinge
on either civil rights or or on the
national commerce our common market that
we have here and we'll have to address
that these are very very burdensome
impingement on Liberty then if he
adopted them we have to remember for the
limited purpose of slowing down the
split that is bending the curve we
didn't adopt them as the comprehensive
way of dealing with this disease well
that is that is right I mean this cannot
be the the new normal camp you stay home
the new normal maybe something that is
annoying like you have to wear a mask
all the time like if to socially
distance in our offices I know that
that's what people are doing right I
mean that's that that is what people are
doing we have a disproportionately young
office and we are in a vital industry so
people are allowed to work at our
offices when I'm violating the law nor
are we encouraging people to do so but
that is going to be something like the
new normal now meanwhile president Trump
finally put out his executive order on
immigration and guess what it's not bad
like there's nothing wrong with the
executive order there there are some
people who say it's not strict enough in
limiting immigration because all it
really does is it temporarily bars a new
immigrants including some family members
of US citizens and foreign workers
looking to move to the United States in
the next 60 days alone under a new
executive order the temporary
immigration a suspension is designed to
reduce immigration at a time when tens
of millions of Americans lost jobs
there's some people who are saying
that's not going to do it I mean a
60-day ban isn't gonna do it because
people aren't even going back to work
many of them in the next 60 days
particularly in areas like New York or
New Jersey the executive work does not
impact immigrants already living in the
United States or foreigners coming on
temporary visas for work or travel so
that means that you're actually not even
decreasing the number of workers which
you know frankly it seems to me that if
you're trying to limit the amount of
labor in American society at a time when
30 million people are out of work which
is not the world's worst idea then this
is insufficient that category includes
h-1b visas which allow more than 85,000
high-skilled foreigners to come to the
United States for at least three years
to work it also includes seasonal
migrant workers who come to the u.s.
annually to work on farms where they
make up about a tenth of the
agricultural workforce and at other
businesses such at resorts and county
and county fairs the executive order is
less restrictive than advocates on both
sides had it earlier
expected it doesn't actually impact most
employment-based immigration so
basically it just says you can't come in
right now mark Krikorian who is it the
the strict on immigration presidents of
the Center for Immigration Studies he
says it's a PR stunt more than anything
else which in vain may very well be so
all of the objections that this is like
the end of the world that's just not
correct that that is not prevented
people from fulminating in the most
idiotic fashion they don't work tweeted
about how he wanted people to work on
the farms I mean honestly for Republican
and tweeted this everybody would be like
this guy's kind of a racist bait
overarch tweeted and and this is Greg sy
get to bring back my bait oh who the
bleep do you think is working on the
farms and feedlots bra in the packing
houses in processing plants at a time
when we are struggling to feed ourselves
kickflip who's in the kitchen
who's picking preparing serving the food
we eat cleaning up afterwards yeah yeah
mmm not great there bado O'Rourke
meanwhile reporters were asking from are
you using the coronavirus to reduce
legal immigration is this your Cruella
Cruella pot again it doesn't actually
reduce even the employment visas that
are coming in really here's a reporter
completely watching the story as per our
usual arrangement in the American media
saying that you are using the virus now
in this crisis to follow through on that
promise to reduce legal no no well I
want people that are in this country I
want our citizens to get jobs I don't
want them to have competition we have a
very unusual situation I don't want them
to compete right now there's a big
difference when we have a full economy
and frankly where some of the companies
we have many companies moving in where
they need actually they need workers
that's a big difference between that and
where all of a sudden a lot of people
lose job okay so again there's the
reporter completely blowing at speaking
of the media completely blowing at the
continued insanity of Chris Cuomo is is
pretty amazing so yesterday Chris Cuomo
emerged from his basement to the wild
cheers of I guess the internal staff at
CNN he emerged from his basement in what
is obviously the most produced video
everywhere anything like of anytime he's
overacting more than the Nicholas Cage
in every Nicolas Cage movie he emerges
from the spaceman out what
various about this of course that CNN's
Chris Cuomo had been spotted like
actually traveling from one of his
houses to a construction site where
construction was taking place in another
one of his houses so this is not the
first time he's emerged from the
basement I guess the idea here was that
if you emerge from the basement then
went back down into the basement then we
would get six more weeks of winter
but here was Chris Cuomo emerging from
the basement over at CNN in the most
dramatic possible fashion from the
basement cleared by CDC little sway just
worked out happens this is what I've
been dreaming of literally for weeks
my wife she was cleared by the CDC she
doesn't have fevers and other symptoms
anymore when the seven days from her
quarantine I'm still a little scared so
I'll just give you one of these just
give you one of these just give you one
of these just give you one of these
Bella has of course taking the video
this is the dream okay except that he
had emerged from that basement many
times before so well then well then CNN
so Chris Cuomo when he is not emerging
in in a fake obviously second take video
when when he's not emerging from his
basement
he is also explained that we're not
seeing urgency from our leaders and this
is the media narrative that drives me up
a wall the media have promoted to
specific lies here lie number one is
that there will come a time in the near
future when we are all safe and we can
all go back to work as normal and that
will require 87 million tests a day and
also it will require a vaccine and
anybody who says differently wants to
kill you
right that is lie number one that is
completely ridiculous flattening the
curve was never about that testing was
never about that so that is deeply
irresponsible of the media the other
thing that the media keeps saying is
that the federal administration because
Trump is the president that they are not
doing sufficient action that they don't
care deeply about this what what are you
talking about what are you talking about
so Akira's Chris Cuomo suggesting we're
not seeing urgency from our leaders are
we really not are we not seeing urgency
from our leaders press como seriously
we've dumped at this point seven
trillion dollars out the door on the
federal level we've created hundreds of
thousands of ventilators right it is
amusing right here's Chris Cuomo
explaining that our leaders are not
showing great urgency in the middle of
the worst pandemic in modern
in history people are doing amazing
things they are all the time to help
other people during this pandemic my
frustration is we need that from our
leaders as well that desperate times
desperate measures doing what you can
we're seeing it in people we're seeing
in our health care workers when not
seeing it with the urgency that we need
to from our leaders yet and that's what
worries me about what the CDC had today
said tonight
well well weird because they Andrew
Cuomo Chris's brother who he when he's
there they basically interview each
other on CNN they have like a buddy cop
show Andrew Cuomo said yesterday that
the White House has been very helpful
and that in fact New York no longer
needs the u.s. ship comfort remember
that comforts steaming into New York
Harbor and it was like a big deal all
the pictures looked unbelievably tragic
inside of two weeks they're saying we
don't need that ship anymore so we're
like where is the lack of urgency
seriously where is it the meeting went
well and I think it was for doctors the
the big issue was testing as everybody
knows that's going to be the next step
as we go forward the president said sent
up a navy ship that comfort it was a
hospital ship which by the way was very
good to have in case we had overflow but
I said we don't really need the comfort
anymore it did give us comfort but we
don't need it anymore so if they need to
deploy that somewhere else they should
take it
not not acting with urgency I mean
everyone is acting with urgency right
now obviously obviously but this
contributes the media's coverage here is
basically just a democratic talking
point because everybody sort of
understands at this point the
administration is doing what they need
to do at least they're doing their best
and yet the Democratic talking point is
that everything the administration does
is insufficient and the only thing that
would be sufficient are things that are
not possible so you end up with people
like Anderson Cooper suggesting on
national television that we need four
million tests per day we don't need four
million tests per day to open that's
insane
and he's saying this to John Kerry
that's not anything like it Scott
Gottlieb right who knows a lot more
about this stuff than Anderson Cooper
said maybe we need 300,000 tests today
to open not four million okay if look
were they getting this crap they're just
pulling it straight out of thin air
here's Anderson Cooper again setting up
a bar that just doesn't does not exist I
mean that bar is not real
we all want to see the economy open
everybody does everybody wants to get
out of their house there are a lot of
safe ways to do it
long but the safest way of all is
clearly by being able to test the virus
itself who has it and being able to test
the antibodies to determine who may have
had it there about 150,000 tests being
done roughly every day right now our
latest Harvard study was showing
initially four million would need to be
done every day maybe going up into
double digits by by July just to get
everything going and and people
confident okay by the way that that
Harvard study did not suggest that that
was going to be the bar to governor's
opening States but the Harvard study
suggested is that if you want people to
like go back to concerts and movie
theaters in mass numbers you need 20
million a day guess what that ain't
happening but the media have been using
that number as a cudgel to wield against
the trumpet well if you don't make 20
millions house available first of all
all of this is basically on governors
remember we have a federalist system
somehow gavin newsom in in in california
was able to obtain enough ventilators
that we were sending ventilators from
this coast to the other coast in the
middle of the pandemic well they can do
the same with with state budgets it
turns out that if states can pay for all
the stupid crap that they pay for they
should be able to pay for some of these
tests but all of this feeds into the
general democratic talking point here
which is that the Trump administration
is a giant failure here's a OC summing
it up suggesting that the government is
responsible for a 9/11 worth of death
every single day we are going to pass a
small potatoes bill and then we are
talking about resetting again until May
4th and if we are going to bring every
member or call back almost every member
of who can back to DC to pass a small
incremental bill and with the knowledge
that we are not coming back until next
month again that's two rent checks and
the last time we left again we lost over
1 9/11 s worth of people due to this
lack of action really the what lack of
action what was that was the action that
was supposed to be taken there wasn't
taken other than Democrats holding up
two separate massive funding bills for a
grand total of two weeks what what
action was not taken this is all part of
the this is the
where is a Democrat media narrative that
does not reflect reality the reality is
the feds are doing what they are
supposed to do and what they can do that
is the reality and the states many of
them are trying to do what they can do
and some of them are overzealous in
doing it and some of them are saying
listen Georgia is not New York but to
pretend that public officials are
insufficiently acting so that you can
elect Democrats is pretty disgusting
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today if you are a music fan
and not too discriminating in your taste
then you might enjoy a video that we
just posted on YouTube my dad and I have
had a little bit of extra time to
practice violin and piano together and
so we put together basically a single
take of Ave Maria by Bach and Gounod's
Ave Lynne believe it or not there are
certain people who clamor for me on
violin I'm not sure why that is but
here's a little bit of the beginning of
Ave Maria by Bob but no you can go see
that on YouTube I think it's got like a
million views on on Facebook you can go
check it out it's kind of fun
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so you can go listen to the whole
thing over there also I believe we are
posting a single tape version of
meditation from Ty east by Jules
Massenet which is one of the more famous
violin solo pieces it's really pretty
piece I think we have that up in
Instagram also so if you enjoy that kind
of thing then then you know see if you
can bear your way through something like
that okay other thing that I like today
one thing that I really do love about
some members of the social left is that
many of the things that they say are
moral they will not engage in themselves
cuz they inherently know they're not
particularly moral now this is not the
libertarian position in the libertarian
position very often is that things that
I don't think are moral are still
allowed in a free society lots of stuff
I don't approve of but that doesn't
actively harm other people it's not
really my job to step in and do
something about that because if we all
use our subjective preferences as to
what is right and wrong but with regard
to things that don't damage other people
that's how you end up with authoritarian
States right that that is the
libertarian position in other words I
explicitly say that things I don't like
are still legal that is not the leftist
position the leftist position is only
things I like should be legal right if I
don't like your language it should be
illegal if you say thing I don't like
it's hate speech if you participate in a
religious service I don't like we should
shut it down if you want to homeschool
your kids that should be illegal we
talked about this a little bit earlier
this week there's a Harvard magazine
piece about how homeschooling should be
illegal because evil evil Christians are
teaching social priorities that this
professor at Harvard does not like so
the leftist position is not a
libertarian one like I don't like this
moral position and therefore it should
but it should still be allowed because I
have a different view of what government
should do than enforce morality know the
leftist position is the government
should enforce morality so therefore the
government should only allow things that
I personally like well this has led some
very weird sort of some weird
contradictions and it leads to this very
puzzle piece that I absolutely love from
mell magazine the the piece was written
by ceci Kuwabara Blanchard it is called
why won't woke
pay for sex bernie bros male feminists
and good guy liberals all support sex
work but for some reason they aren't
paying girls like me for sex for months
before violet a 25 year old transsexual
with dollish cheekbones and primary
color wardrobe moved to Brooklyn she
toyed with the idea of holding a
farewell tour in her lifelong home of
Portland Oregon her approach to putting
a bow on her 20-plus years in a city
mock firts liberal leanings was to
collide her two disparate worlds her
friend circle of jewel puffing mulleted
bernie bros with her recent professional
foray into bleeping for cash what if I
put it out there that I'm available as a
sex worker for people I know for highly
discounted rates if violet now a good
friend of mine recently tells me over
FaceTime recalling the logic behind her
maniac idea she admits it was both a
stab at giving her friends a last chance
to eff while also raking in as much
money as she could before she had the
Big Apple violet took to Instagram
stories to vibe check these guys if
you're someone who supports sex work at
an intellectual level
would you ever hire a sex worker
yourself she wrote she assumed that her
peers Millennials umer cusps with art
degrees and hard-ons for progressive
politics would be prime clients after
all as youngish liberals they seem to
overwhelmingly support sex workers and
the decriminalization of their
profession and they were right in line
with those of others in their
demographic categories
despite stereotypes of John's being
unattractive older men some research
shows that clients of sex workers tend
to have their first experience of paid
sex when they're young hot and in their
20s in other words the numbers that
suggests that more of violence followers
should have been down with paid sex
that's not what happened the woke guys
in her social circle who responded
weren't bringing the same kind of hoorah
they had for the idea of standing in
solidarity with sex workers and exactly
none of them offered to cough up cash
that left her confused if these young
dudes were politically rooting for sex
workers and are in the period of their
lives and they're most likely to first
see one why aren't they seizing on mass
the opportunity for one of violets
bargain bin leaps or one of those
friendly neighborhood sex workers for
that matter
some have pragmatic excuses of course I
don't have the money I don't want sex
that bad I can get bleeped without
paying for it they DM violet but it's
more than that as to trans girls who
keep leftist male hotties in their
company and turn tricks as a side hustle
violet and I both have observed that our
peers can't get our politics straight
for one these guys support
decriminalizing sex work because they're
feminists but they also seem to not pay
for a sec
because they're feminists so they are
they are so woke that they are all in
favor of people being paid for sex like
they think it's perfectly moral to pay
for sex but also they think it's a
little bit immoral to pay for sex
because that might be violating feminist
precepts because the feminist movement
is is actually confused about this thing
so they are confused similarly also it
turns out a lot of people on the left
the social policies that they proclaim
are actually moral and decent and
wonderful they were engaged in
themselves right so the great example of
this hollywood is constantly promoting
single motherhood constantly talk about
single motherhood is not only a valid
life choice but a heroic life choice
that if you're a single mother you hood
so you're more heroic in some fashion
than a woman who got married and settled
down and had a family right that's the
easy decision being a single mother and
kicking dad out of the house because
he's a bad guy that you decided to have
sex with irresponsibly and now you have
a baby that's actually a brave decision
according to most Hollywood NTV films
right that is that is what Hollywood
promotes but nobody in Hollywood
actually lives like that the marriage
rates in Hollywood are very very high
they're not a lot of single mothers in
Hollywood why well because it turns out
that in people's actual lives the moral
decisions that they make are not the
moral decisions that they promote so
there is a great irony to these this
article from Mel magazine lamenting that
number one a lot of leftist guys who say
that trans women are women will not have
sex with the trans woman because it
turns out that trans women are not in
fact women and so they're very upset
about this right that very very upset
and I find that hilarious and then I
also find it hilarious that the feminist
movement has created such insecurity in
feminists and feminists Bernie bros that
the feminist Bernie Bros on the one hand
they're like yeah all in for sex work
sex works great man liberation
liberation also I I can't engage in that
because I think it would be somehow
victimizing you and I've been told by
some feminists that sex work is actually
demeaning to women and objectifying
women so well I think it's gung-ho go
for and me personally no on that no on
that so that what this this holistic
worldview has not been particularly
successful on the left so I am enjoying
that according to the smell magazine
piece woke boys are likely not just
swerving around paid sex because of
their
mixed-signal feminism the refusal to pay
for sex also seems to come from
believing a john to be the antithesis of
a successful heterosexual male because
you see they're mean to John's like if
you have to pay for sex somehow you are
lesser you are lesser which is
discriminatory
according to mel magazine is it possible
that Wow
is it possible that maybe this moral
code does not stand up to any level of
realistic scrutiny Brad had only ever
been with cisgender women he told me I
was his first knowing this I checked in
with him multiple times throughout the
night to make sure his heterosexual ego
was still intact I couldn't help but
feel the whole lot a flirtation and why
date was a charade to bed me secure his
fantasy and then return to his
sister or friend if he was looking to
bleep a girl's male genitalia he should
have just paid a prostitute ideally me
um that's not the straightest thing I'm
just gonna put that out there not the
straightest activity the the self
contradictions in the feminist movement
are extraordinarily hilarious and and
well deserving of mockery so thank you
mel magazine i really appreciated that
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so Joe Biden continues to not be
sentient Joe Biden continues to not be
able to string sentences together
yesterday like every livestream he holds
an eye lives from everyday and I'm sure
I make errors but not errors like this
every livestream and Joe Biden has he
makes errors not because he's distracted
but because he is not with us Joe Biden
is clearly not with us in the way that
entering the latter part of his last
term Woodrow Wilson was not with us and
his wife and then an Edith ended up
governing the country basically for the
last year and a half of the Wilson
administration Joe Biden just yesterday
he was doing his livestream from his
basement and he confused Labor Day
Memorial Day and called the the
Pennsylvania Governor Dale instead of
Tom who's a completely different human
being here was here was Joe Biden just
screwing things up left and right and
all Dale's been saying governor wolf is
listen to the scientists do you think
we'll have a candidate by the Memorial
Day I I'm quite sure that'd be the case
because right now the convention is
scheduled in August before Memorial Day
are you saying Memorial or Labor I said
Memorial Day oh no no no it won't be
before Memorial Day no it won't would
you were just getting the process
underway yeah um so he's not with us Joe
Biden but he is thinking about Michelle
Obama as a potential VP pick now I
thought we were done with sort of the
era Trump was a ringing rebuke of the
era of sort of he family politics right
because we'd had two bushes and so the
idea of Jeb was just unpalatable to a
lot of Republicans and then we'd already
had Bill Clinton and Hillary was running
and people were like what would not
super into that so now Joe wants to
bring in Michelle I understand why
Michelle Obama has done a magnificent
job of remaking herself from the radical
she was in 2008 talking about how this
is the first time she was proud of her
country was her husband's nomination she
has remade herself into a sort of
late-night TV host figure or mid day TV
host figure inspiring and a political
and obviously Joe Biden is trying to
appeal to the black community by saying
that he would pick Michelle Obama as his
running mate here he is
I've heard some speculation about
Michelle Obama his vice president if she
said to you she'd be willing to be your
running mate would you ask her
oh I'd take her in a heartbeat she's
she's brilliant she's she knows the way
around she is a really fine woman okay
so he obviously is trying to pander her
what's hilarious though and this is the
part I hate is the pandering in the
Democratic Party is actually not
directed at black Americans the people
who actually care in America about the
race of the presidential candidate it
turns out our bunch of walk white
liberals and that those are the people
who actually care okay that is according
to Pew Research data so there they put
out a poll in the last couple of weeks
and what they found is that here's the
question regardless of who you supported
for the Democratic nomination would you
say that the fact that the likely
Democratic nominee is a white man in his
70s either bothers you or doesn't bother
you so 59% of all Democrats and leaning
Democrats registered voters say it
doesn't bother them them
forty-one percent say that it bothers
them now here's the breakdown by race
and here's where it gets super hilarious
among black Americans asked whether it
bothers them that the nominee is a is an
old white man 72% of black voters say no
we don't care 72 percent say it doesn't
bother us at all only 20
8% says bother say it bothers them among
Hispanics 70% says say it doesn't bother
me and only 30% say that it bothers them
among white Democrats 51% say it doesn't
bother me
49% say it bothers me so suppose you
woke white liberals the sort of people
pay Sarah rau to talk about how racist
they are at dinner parties at $300
dinner parties with Cabernet Sauvignon
on the table and and a nice red meat
vegan steak right then those sorts of
people are the ones who are super
bothered by the fact that you Abidin is
old and white it isn't actually black
americans why because i think that the
the idea that black americans believe
that america is inherently deeply
unapologetically and forever racist I
think that's overplayed I think the
media overplayed that I think the people
in the media are all white woke liberals
who say that they are bothered by this
sort of stuff and then they go vote for
Joe Biden anyways they're just a bunch
of hypocrites by the way the breakdown
by age is not particularly is not
particularly stellar either so older
Democrats say they don't care that the
Democrat is a white man in his 70s
that's basically everybody above the age
of 50 in the Democratic Party says they
don't care if you are thirty to forty
nine fifty five percent of Democrats say
they don't care about the fact that
Biden is old and white if you are
eighteen to twenty nine fifty four
percent say that they care about this
which is not good for the future of
America if you look at a nominee and
your first reaction is I don't like that
guy's race and I don't like that guy's
age it's weird because if Republicans
were to say you know that guy seems too
old then all of a sudden it's look at
how Aegeus they are and if they say well
look at that another white guy huh hmm
so well how about that that fabled
diversity and as I look at them and the
Republicans shouldn't talk about this if
the younger part of our country is
interested in the sort of woke virtue
signaling attendant here then that is
very bad news by the way the other thing
you see is that there isn't doctrine
ation going on at these at these
colleges at these universities you would
think that racial politics would be the
preserve of people who are who are less
educated right this is always what
people say in the Republican parties
that the people who are most racist are
the people who are less educated
opposite in the Democratic Party
apparently if you're a post-grad worker
if you're a post graduate and post
graduate degree 58% of people with a
postgraduate degree say they're bothered
that Joe Biden is old and white if
you're a high schooler said
6% say they are bothered are not
bothered by the fact that Joe Biden is
old and white so just shows you where
the Democratic Party is and that is that
is bad for the future of the country if
you are breaking people down by race and
by age in order to determine their merit
you are doing all of these things wrong
and yet the Democratic Party as it gets
younger and more educated is actually
moving in the wrong direction
hilariously enough it is the racially
divergent contingent the racially
diverse contingent of the Democratic
Party that is still tethered to some
form of reality all the white woke
liberals have completely lost it they've
completely lost touch with reality and
and they deserve what they get they
deserve what they get here alrighty well
we'll be back here to do two additional
hours of content also make sure that 4
p.m. today Pacific time you come by for
our daily wire backstage we're socially
distancing it shall be a party and since
I'm forced to be here you should be here
too I'll see you a little bit later
today or see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Hoss directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director pavel
white house key technical producer
austin stevens playback and media
operated by nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
SIA vets audio is mixed by micro Romina
hair and makeup is by Nika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you